Trascrizione: Alessandra Pompei
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quando si inizia un dottorato,
una delle cose più difficili
è trovare una domanda:
una domanda di ricerca
su cui non si sappia già abbastanza,
e che sia interessante da scoprire.
E su cui, soprattutto,
ci sia il proprio interesse
a dedicarsi giorno -
e a volte, anche notte -
per tutti gli anni successivi.
Quando io ho iniziato
il mio dottorato, nel 2007,
mi è stato da subito chiaro
che solo studiare come le imprese
avrebbero potuto migliorare
le proprie performance finanziarie -
io ho iniziato un dottorato
in Economia e Management -
non era sufficiente per me.
Io volevo dedicare le mie ore e giorni,
le mie notti, a fare qualcosa di più:
io volevo salvare il mondo.
Sì, avevo aspirazioni importanti.
Ci ho messo più di un anno:
e poi, ho trovato quelle
che sono state le due parole chiave
attorno alle quali avrei costruito
il mio progetto di ricerca.
La prima: "innovazione".
Che significa come le imprese
cambiano quello che fanno,
quello che producono
e il modo in cui lo fanno.
E la seconda: "sostenibilità ambientale",
che significa - beh, su questo oggi
non serve dare una spiegazione.
Almeno non oggi, non a voi;
ma dieci, 15 anni fa
ricordo che non erano molte,
le imprese che erano consapevoli
di cosa stavo parlando.
E ricordo che passavo da fabbrica a evento
cercando di spiegare
perché mettere la sostenibilità ambientale
al centro delle scelte di innovazione,
di sviluppo di un nuovo prodotto,
era fondamentale, era una scelta
strategica per le imprese.
Adesso, invece, non c'è evento
in cui non ci sia la parola "green",
"circolare", "sostenibile",
in almeno uno degli
interventi dell'evento.
E infatti, se guardiamo ai numeri,
negli ultimi anni si è fatto tantissimo
in tema di sostenibilità,
si sono sviluppati grandissimi progetti
e quasi tutte le imprese
hanno cominciato a mettersi in gioco,
per quanto riguarda la sostenibilità.
Prendiamo, ad esempio,
la riduzione di gas serra:
be', nel 2020, delle 4000 imprese
più grandi nel mondo -
più grandi per ricavi -
il 65% aveva piani dettagliati
su come ridurrà, nei prossimi anni,
le proprie emissioni.
Era solo il 50%, fino a tre anni fa.
Benissimo!
Ma se andiamo poi a vedere
quelli che sono poi
le emissioni di gas serra,
vediamo che siamo ancora lontani
dal raggiungere i nostri obiettivi.
E in effetti, se andiamo a leggere
tra quelle dichiarazioni delle imprese
e anche ci focalizziamo
solo sulle imprese del G7,
e su quelle quotate in Borsa -
quindi, insomma quelle
che hanno più risorse -
be', vediamo che il 75%
di questi obiettivi
è stato dichiarato non valido.
Ma "non valido" non perché
non porti a cambiamenti,
o non ci siano effettivamente
stati investimenti,
o non abbia portato a cambiare qualcosa;
ma perché quei cambiamenti
non sono quello che serve,
perché quei cambiamenti
non sono quanto serve
per raggiungere quella soglia
dell'1,5 gradi.
Lasciate che vi faccia un esempio,
per spiegarvi cosa intendo.
Avete presente l'iniziativa
di piantumare alberi,
per compensare le emissioni di CO2?
Be', se veramente dovessimo piantare
tutti gli alberi che sono stati dichiarati
nei vari report di imprese e istituzioni,
beh, probabilmente dovremmo creare
un nuovo pianeta, per farceli stare tutti.
E allora perché?
Perché, se c'è voglia di cambiare,
se si investe nel cambiamento,
se le imprese fanno cose,
non si ottengono i risultati sperati?
Perché cambiare non è così facile?
Come mai è così complesso
raggiungere questo risultato?
Effettivamente, non solo
ridurre i miei impatti,
non solo inquinare un po' meno
di quello che facevo ieri,
ma proprio andare a ridurre
il problema ambientale,
quello è una storia molto più complessa.
E lasciate che ve la spieghi,
questa complessità della sostenibilità,
a partire anche da esempi molto quotidiani
e usando quello che, forse,
è un mantra che conosciamo tutti,
quello delle tre R.
E quello che voglio raccontarvi
non è tanto che innovare,
cambiare non sia possibile;
ma quanto, se lo facciamo
in modo semplicistico,
a volte abbiamo più problemi
di quelli che risolviamo.
Progettare nuovi prodotti
con materiali riciclabili
è sostenibile, no?
No, se poi quel prodotto alla fine
non riusciamo a riciclarlo.
Prendete l'oblò della vostra lavatrice:
vetro; plastica; alluminio.
Tutti materiali riciclabili, no?
Sì: ma voglio vedervi poi,
quando la lavatrice non funziona più,
a separarli
per metterli nei giusti cassonetti
e distinguere le materie prime.
A meno che quel prodotto
non fosse stato pensato dall'inizio,
per essere disassemblabile a fine vita.
Riutilizzare, acquistare
un prodotto di seconda mano:
beh, questo sì che è sostenibile, no?
Evito di usare materie prime vergini,
evito di creare rifiuti.
Eh, no, se usare quel prodotto
crea più problemi di quello che risolve.
Uno studio commissionato da Patagonia
ha confrontato le emissioni
di microplastiche, di microfibre,
ad ogni lavaggio,
confrontando delle giacche -
di quelle sintetiche, tecniche,
progettate dieci, 20 anni fa -
con altre più recenti.
Quello che si è scoperto
è che, ad ogni lavaggio,
le giacche che sono state progettate
in un'ottica più di economia lineare,
senza pensare a quelli che sarebbero stati
gli impatti a fine vita,
lasciano ad ogni lavaggio il 60%
di microfibre, di microplastiche in più.
E molto dipende, anche,
da come lo facciamo, quel lavaggio.
Ridurre?
Essere più efficienti?
Aumentare l'efficienza e le risorse?
Quello sì sarà sostenibile, no?
No, se poi questa efficienza
porta a un uso maggiore
della risorsa stessa.
Prendete il settore del traffico aereo:
negli ultimi 70 anni, ci sono state
incredibili trasformazioni tecnologiche
che hanno ridotto di più di 20 volte
le emissioni per passeggero.
Però, in questo lasso di tempo,
c'è stato anche un altrettanto incredibile
aumento del numero di passeggeri,
anche motivato dal fatto
che i prezzi più accessibili,
motivati dagli avvicendamenti,
hanno reso più facile viaggiare.
Questo aumento di passeggeri
ha più che compensato i risparmi,
ed oggi abbiamo più di sette volte
più emissioni di quelle
che c'erano 70 anni fa.
E allora, vedete: insomma,
far bene non è sufficiente:
è necessario, sì, ma non è sufficiente
per veramente cambiare le cose.
E se affrontiamo la sostenibilità
in maniera semplicistica,
senza andare veramente a vedere
gli impatti delle azioni che realizzo,
ecco: rischio di creare più problemi
di quelli che vado a risolvere.
È questa la complessità
che devono affrontare le imprese.
A cui, però, si aggiunge
anche un'altra complessità.
Prendete un prodotto
che avete davanti a voi,
qualcosa che indossate,
quello che state usando adesso,
magari per guardarmi, per ascoltarmi.
Quello che vedete è un prodotto unico, no?
Immaginate un oggetto monolitico:
c'è un unico nome
di un'impresa scritto sopra.
Eppure, dietro questa apparenza
in realtà c'è un puzzle di componenti
realizzati da un grande numero
di imprese diverse,
ognuna specializzata
in una fase produttiva
necessaria per realizzare quel prodotto,
e magari localizzata in paesi
con un diverso grado
di attenzione alla sostenibilità,
diverse regolamentazioni,
diverse pressioni sociali.
Prendete un iPhone:
180 componenti diversi,
realizzati da una fitta rete di fornitori
che spazia dagli Stati Uniti al Giappone,
dalla Corea del Sud all'Italia.
Oppure, anche, prendete un prodotto
più semplice, come una scarpa:
una scarpa da donna col tacco
ha più di 40 componenti diverse.
Allora, capite che se noi vogliamo
che l'intero prodotto sia sostenibile,
è necessario che tutte le imprese
che fanno parte di quel puzzle
abbiano progettato
con materiali sostenibili,
siano stati attenti a ridurre gli impatti
dei propri processi produttivi,
abbiano ragionato
in un'ottica di fine vita,
cercando di ridurre gli impatti
alla fine dell'uso del prodotto.
E che queste azioni
siano coordinate tra di loro;
o almeno, che non si intralcino.
Cosa vuol dire "che non si intralcino"?
Lasciate che ve lo spieghi
ritornando a quella scarpa,
che magari avete comprato
in un negozio di brand francese,
che l'ha fatta realizzare
da dei calzaturifici rumeni,
che hanno utilizzato della pelle
che è stata conciata in Italia,
a partire da un pellame
che è venuto dal Brasile.
Ecco: cosa vuol dire
che quella scarpa sia "sostenibile"?
Se lo chiedete al brand,
affinché il loro prodotto sia sostenibile,
vuol dire "vendere un prodotto che è fatto
con materie prime sostenibili,
quindi ad esempio materie
che non contengano metalli pesanti".
Se invece lo chiedete alla conceria,
per la conceria fare una pelle sostenibile
significa fare una pelle
che non non produce impatti,
soprattutto nell'acqua,
quando viene prodotta.
Penserete: "Qual è il problema?
Si possono fare entrambe le cose!".
Ma la realtà è
che se il brand chiede alla conceria
di fare una pelle senza metalli pesanti,
la conceria finisce per cambiare
completamente processo produttivo,
ma fare una pelle che non è
veramente resistente.
E se vuole, comunque, avere
una pelle resistente a sufficienza
per essere un prodotto
vendibile, e venduto,
allora dovrà usare,
in una fase produttiva successiva,
un numero maggiore di prodotti chimici.
Per cui, alla fine, le emissioni totali...
Tutti e due questi attori
hanno fatto tanto,
hanno cambiato molto di quello che fanno;
però le due cose si sono bilanciate,
e alla fine, non necessariamente
si sono ridotti gli impatti.
Allora, capite che quando
la complessità della sostenibilità
incontra la complessità
delle catene globali del valore,
la complessità della sostenibilità
diventa una complessità al quadrato.
Perché non basta solo verificare
che all'azione ci sia un risultato,
che effettivamente quella sia
l'azione che serve
per andare a ridurre gli impatti:
e guardate, non è così scontato.
Ma devo, anche, verificare
che la mia azione sia coordinata
con quella degli altri.
E quindi, vi starete chiedendo:
cosa fare, davanti a questa complessità?
Cosa possiamo fare?
Come scegliere di confrontarsi
con questo con questa situazione?
Potremmo rinunciare:
perché già riciclare,
riutilizzare è faticoso;
e se poi, magari, lo faccio
e non ha i risultati sperati?
Oppure, potrei delegare:
che ci pensino altri
a gestire la sostenibilità,
qualcuno che può scoprire
la nuova tecnologia che ci salverà,
oppure i politici
che hanno in mano molte scelte,
oppure chi inquina di più;
oppure chi è più ricco,
che ha più risorse -
comunque, qualcun altro.
Oppure potrei rinunciare
perché nella mia vita, nel mondo,
ci sono altre priorità oggi, no?
Potremmo certamente scegliere
di affrontare così,
questa complessità della sostenibilità.
E tra 30 anni se ci guardassimo indietro,
nessuno potrebbe guardarci e dire:
è stata colpa tua, tua, tua,
della situazione in cui siamo.
Nessuno potrebbe dircelo, è vero.
Ma pensate a che futuro diverso,
se già oggi noi tutti cominciassimo
a costruirlo, un futuro diverso,
e scegliessimo di affrontare
questa complessità
in maniera differente?
E come, vi chiederete:
ma come affrontare questa complessità?
Vi ricordate la domanda di ricerca,
la domanda del dottorato?
Ecco, è proprio questa
la domanda che mi sono fatta:
come può fare un'azienda a,
veramente, ridurre gli impatti
se anche non è responsabile
di tutte le attività
che bisognerebbe cambiare?
E quello che ho scoperto,
io e i tanti colleghi
che lavoriamo in questi ambiti,
può essere utile
non solo per un manager alle prese
con le proprie scelte quotidiane,
ma anche per te,
che sei un designer di prodotto;
oppure un consumatore
che è intenzionato a scegliere
tra un prodotto e l'altro;
oppure è un semplice cittadino
che sta scegliendo come dedicare
il proprio tempo libero;
o una neolaureata
che sta scegliendo a cosa dedicare
il proprio tempo lavorativo.
Cosa ho scoperto?
Che i problemi si risolvono
quando non si ignorano,
quando non cerchiamo risposte semplici
a problemi complessi,
quando non cerchiamo soluzioni facili,
che ci alleggeriscono la coscienza
ma non alleggeriscono
i problemi sull'ambiente.
Che per trovare soluzioni efficaci
è importante che ci informiamo -
tutti, oggi.
Che cominciamo a guardare, cercare,
capire un po di più
come si possono fare le cose davvero,
per ridurre gli impatti ambientali.
E ho scoperto che i problemi
non sono limiti,
ma sono punti di partenza.
E che a volte, anche solo facendosi
domande semplici come:
"A cosa serve, veramente,
questo prodotto?"
Oppure: "Questo prodotto
mi serve davvero? "
E facendosi domande anche così semplici,
possiamo creare
delle soluzioni incredibili.
E non servono, sempre,
grandi tecnologie, molto costose;
ma a volte sono, anche,
cose molto più semplici
con cui riusciamo a cambiare il mondo,
a cambiare le cose
partendo dal farci le domande giuste.
E infine, l'ultima strategia
per affrontare la complessità,
e quella che è la più importante di tutte,
quella che tutte le contiene:
la collaborazione.
Perché se non ci percepiamo
come parte di un sistema più grande,
non risolveremo mai i problemi
ambientali del nostro tempo.
E non lo faremo mai,
a meno che cerchiamo degli alleati,
o altri soggetti che hanno
i nostri stessi problemi ambientali,
oppure chi potrebbe avere
le risorse complementari
per aiutarci a risolverli;
o infine, qualcuno a cui possiamo unirci
per far sentire meglio la nostra voce.
Perché una cosa
l'ho capita, in questi anni:
nessuno può salvare il mondo da solo.
Ma là fuori ci sono aziende, imprenditori,
cittadini, associazioni, cooperative -
ce ne sono tantissime
che stanno facendo cose straordinarie.
Allora, cominciate a cercarli già oggi,
cercate quello che è più vicino a voi,
che potete contribuire in qualunque modo,
qui dove siete, per cambiare le cose.
Nessuno salva il mondo da solo:
e la sostenibilità è, sì, difficile:
è come una vetta da scalare.
Ma ora, anche voi conoscete
gli strumenti per scalarla.
Io sono sicura che se li useremo,
e se saliremo tutti in cordata,
allora sì, tra 30 anni, guardando avanti,
potremo finalmente vedere
il futuro che vogliamo.
(Applausi)